for the federal government to come in
and really tie school nutrition and
school lunch programs to this radical
ideology is is terrifying and it's
appalling
the changes that the divided
administration is making to the the
school lunch program
which essentially amounts to
the body administration holding
states and local school districts
hostage with school lunch money that
goes to you know underprivileged youth
in order to pass transgender
non-discrimination policies as they call
them and you know this means that if a
school does not create a policy that
allows biological boys to use a girl's
bathroom or locker room or facilities
and vice versa then they would have
their funding pulled for this school
lunch program how big is the scope of
this program it's going to apply to all
government schools it's also going to
apply to any private schools
that may take advantage of this lunch
program when you're looking at you know
the usda press release and the usda
press release essentially telling local
school districts what they must do and
how they must operate is a vast
overreach of federal power in what
should be very local you know it is
clear what they are trying to do here
which is a federal takeover
of school systems throughout the country
based on this radical gender ideology i
honestly have no idea how
providing nutrition to children and
providing food to children in schools is
somehow connected to
transgender policies or you know gender
policies it makes absolutely no sense to
me what we see here is the bidet
administration using children as pawns
in this social justice gender ideology
game that they are playing they are
literally putting kids health right
there at the center and saying listen if
you guys want want these school lunches
if you want funding to feed children
you're going to have to do exactly what
we say despite the fact that you know i
would suggest a large segment a vast
majority of parents do not want girls
using boys bathrooms and vice versa do
not want boys playing in girls sports
and
you know they simply
do not approve of these it's absolutely
hypocritical i mean that you know they
discuss equity
uh
non-stop in the body administration in
several states but in reality
if you want to talk about equity or
equal opportunity as i would prefer the
best way to do that is to make sure
that every child has the opportunity to
succeed and one way to do that is to
make sure that they are properly fed but
instead instead of focusing on
excellence in education instead of
focusing on making sure that students
from all areas regardless of their zip
code are provided for and have that
opportunity they are focusing on a small
subset of the population and they're
essentially trying to radicalize schools
to the great disadvantage of children
that need the most help in order to
succeed
quite frankly i think what the bible
administration doing is doing here is
going to be subject to significant legal
challenges i mean they are going to find
themselves in litigation over these
issues for years perhaps until
the end of biden's term
and so
you know it's really
it's stunning just
how aggressively
and how
unabashedly the bite administration is
you know violating all principles of
federalism and essentially demanding
that schools
implement policies that are arguably
unconstitutional